[Applause]
there is a misconception about
chameleons that they change their color
in order to blend in with their
environment
that is actually not the case
when a chameleon is calm it is green and
so it naturally blends in with its leafy
surroundings but male chameleons change
color when they become excited in the
presence of a female or a rival male as
shown here i'll put the first frame in
the bottom right for comparison
as you can see as he becomes more
excited his color changes to be more
yellow orange and red
so instead of blending in this chameleon
will now stand out
but how do chameleons actually change
their color
for years we thought that there was a
simple well-established mechanism for
this color change in their skin
chameleons have different cells
containing colored pigments some are
yellow others are red and some contain
the dark melanin pigment
many animals including chameleons are
known to turn a darker shade by causing
the melanin to spread out along the
fingery extensions of the cell they turn
lighter again by condensing the pigment
back into one spot it was assumed that
chameleons must turn yellow orange and
red in the same way by causing those
pigments to spread out in those cells
but new research from collaborating
groups of physicists and biologists at
the university of geneva shows that this
is incorrect now the first clue should
come from the fact that there is
actually no green pigment in a chameleon
the green color is actually created by
two distinct mechanisms pigment color
and structural color beneath the yellow
pigment cells there are cells containing
tiny 130 nanometer crystals regularly
arranged in a lattice now light
diffracts off these crystals and due to
the spacing between them blue light
constructively interferes and is
therefore strongly reflected whereas the
other colors are not reflected
this is very similar to how a morpho
butterfly wing creates an iridescent
blue there is no blue pigment just the
periodic nanoscale structure that acts
as a strong reflector for only one color
so a chameleon looks green due to the
combination of the yellow light from the
pigment plus the blue light reflected
off the crystal structure beneath it so
how do chameleons change this green into
yellow orange and red well previously it
was assumed that the color change was
achieved by dispersing pigments in the
colored cells
but now scientists have found it's
actually the crystals underneath which
are changing
by increasing the spacing between the
crystals the chameleons can change which
color is selectively reflected bigger
gaps between the crystals are better at
reflecting longer wavelengths so as the
spacing increases the color changes from
blue to green
to yellow and then orange and red
scientists compared skin samples from
calm green chameleons and excited yellow
chameleons and found that indeed in the
excited chameleon the crystal spacing
was much further apart
here you can see a single cell enlarged
and the color it reflects changing from
blue to green to yellow orange and red
plus a computer simulation of the light
reflected off crystals while their
spacing is decreasing also provides
excellent agreement with these
observations
furthermore applying physical pressure
to the skin causes the crystals to
compress and so they reflect more blue
light when that pressure is removed the
crystals expand again reflecting more
green light
the structure of a chameleon skin gets
even more fascinating as there's another
layer of cells underneath which also
contain crystals but these crystals are
larger more spaced out and more
disorganized this means they reflect
longer wavelengths in the infrared part
of the spectrum and they reflect a
broader range of these wavelengths it's
thought that the function of this layer
could be to reflect heat from the sun
since these chameleons live in bright
full sun habitats so male chameleons
don't change their color hue by
spreading out red and yellow pigments
instead they do something much more
remarkable they actively tune the
spacing between nanoscale crystals in
order to create structural colors that
span the whole length of the visible
spectrum
now what i find amazing is that in this
day and age we thought we had the answer
to how chameleons change color but it
actually took the combined expertise of
physicists and biologists working
together to figure out what's really
going on
this episode of veritasium was supported
by lynda.com a leading online learning
platform with over 3 000 video courses
taught by experts in areas ranging from
video production to web development and
computer programming chances are if you
can think of a topic they have a course
that teaches it now as part of this
sponsorship they are offering veritasium
viewers a 10-day free trial of any and
all courses on the site just go to
lynda.com veritasium or click the link
in the description you know one of the
courses i'm really interested in is
adobe after effects that's a really good
animating software right now i still do
all of my animations including the ones
in this video in final cut pro which is
really tedious and time consuming now if
you're interested in learning how to
program maybe you should try out their
java courses those are really good or if
like me you've always wanted to do more
with photoshop you should try out one of
their photoshop or photography courses
so if you want to learn something new
today you should go to lynda.com
veritasium for 10 days free trial
there's really nothing to lose i really
want to thank lynda.com for supporting
me and i want to thank you for watching